also ich habe mich im Jahr 2021 zweimal
impfen lassen das war ich mein Wunsch
sondern es war von meinem diensthandwerk
wünscht er uns auch die die Impftermine
besorgt hatte also quasi dafür gesorgt
hat dass wir uns alle geimpft haben und
ein halbes Jahr nach der zweiten Impfung
habe ich dann immer später
diagnostiziert hat eine
Herzmuskelentzündung bekommen das ist
eine typische Nebenfolge der 19 Impfung
dann habe ich wieder ein halbes Jahr
später eine Thrombose bekommen im Blick
unterschenk auch Thrombosen sind
typische Folgen der Impfung dann im
Oktober ein Schlaganfall hervorgerufen
durch zomben beides sind auch typische
Nebenwirkungen oder Folgen der 19
Impfung und dann sind die Truppen auch
ins Herz gewandert und haben bei mir die
Herzkranzgefäße zerstört so dass ich
fünf Dance bekommen musste und auch noch
ein Herzinfarkt gelitten habe also jede
Menge schwerwiegende Erkrankungen die
auch zum Tode hätten führen können von
daher also nicht beklage ich nicht meine
Schicksal dass ich das alles hatte
sondern ich freue mich dass ich immer
noch lebe und das ist ein Wunder muss
man sagen wenn man diese Anreihung hört
dass Sie heute hier sitzen daher wichtig
wie geht es Ihnen heute sie war
natürlich lange arbeitsunfähig konnten
nicht arbeiten jetzt haben sie glaube
ich es vor kurzem auch wieder angefangen
wieder zurück in den Job als Richter wie
geht's Ihnen heute sehr viele besser
also das
dramatischste was ich hatte war bei dem
Schlaganfall wobei ich da auch Glück
hatte ich habe also keine körperlichen
Einschränkungen bekommen keine
Sprachstörung aber ich hatte einen
vorübergehenden völligen Verlust des
Gleichgewicht sonst wusste also nicht wo
oben unten rechts links war da können
sie sich nicht auf den beinhalten da
gehen sie unweigerlich zu Boden so ist
mir das auch klar geworden da hatte ich
gerade eine mündliche Verhandlung gehabt
und auf dem Weg zu meinem
Bruder haben meine Beine versagt und ich
lag dann auf dem Boden und musste dann
sehen wie ich dann mein so kriechen
konnte was mir noch genommen weil ich
habe das auch für die falsche
eingeschätzt ich dachte deswegen
irgendwelche Kreislaufstörung jemand hat
das so ernst genommen das ist dann ist
ein paar Tage später diagnostiziert
worden dass das ein Schlaganfall war wir
haben sie sich aufgehoben und geholfen
gefühlt haben sie auch den Zusammenhang
der hergestellt mit Hilfe von Ärzten das
muss von der Impfung irgendwie gekommen
sein es gibt immer mehr Medien die auch
jetzt darüber berichten dass es
Impfschäden gibt es gibt Menschen die
darum kämpfen dass diese auch als solche
anerkannt werden das ist aber für viele
die das Annehmen ein schwieriger Weg und
es ist vor allem ja auch schwer diesen
Zusammenhang medizinisch darzustellen
wie war da für Sie genau das habe ich
jetzt auch noch nicht bekommen also dass
das im Schäden sind steht nicht dass du
sicher Sicht fest dass sie nicht
bewiesen es ist nur sehr sehr
wahrscheinlich überwiegend
wahrscheinlich ich bin jetzt auch gerade
erst vor wenigen Tagen aus der
Rehaklinik entlassen worden also noch
keine Gelegenheit mich darum zu kümmern
dass feststellen zu lassen aber ich muss
weiterhin auch damit leben dass man das
nicht wahrhaben will dass das bei mir da
liegen kann nachdem wo er das kann ja
gar nicht sein und gerade so viele
Folgen das ist ja unwahrscheinlich und
das hast du dir doch alles nur
ausgedacht also so ja natürlich selbst
so sicher dass sie sagen dass das war
die ja es sind eben irgendwelche Sachen
und auch verschiedene also auch die
Herzmuskelentzündung die ich zu dir hat
ja eigentlich nichts mit der mit den
ganzen anderen Sachen zu tun durch die
durch trocken gekommen sind ist aber die
häufigste
Nebenfolge und das sind eben Sachen die
ich habe also keinerlei Indikationen für
all diese Sachen hier in meiner Familie
gibt's nichts in meiner Lebensgeschichte
gibt es nicht die einzige Indikation
genau die war vorher immer gesagt der
einzige Indikation die man feststellen
kann die das ausgelöst haben kann ist
eben die Impfungen ansonsten würde man
sagen ich habe eben unwahrscheinliches
Pech gehabt und nur so viel Pech das
fand ich für eher unwahrscheinlich haben
Sie das Gefühl ihnen wird da jetzt auf
diesem Weg Zusammenhänge herzustellen
ihre eigene Krankheitsgeschichte
aufzuarbeiten viel geholfen oder wird
das eher geblockt damit wir nicht
geholfen das muss ich sicherlich alles
setzen Unternehmen
auf sich alleine geschätzt sie haben
eine ziemlich dramatische Geschichte wir
haben gerade gesagt ein Wunder dass sie
hier sitzen wenn Sie alles aufzählen da
würde ja eine Sache reichen dicke für
einen Menschenleben gefallen wenn man
daraus den Schluss ziehen würde dass der
die Behauptung die Impfung sei
ungefährlich und neben Folgen sein so
unwahrscheinlich dass man das vereinen
kann aufgegeben würde und darauf
hinweisen kann das durchaus damals hatte
ich neben Folgen entstehen kann
unabhängig ist von meinem Fall ob das so
ist aber es gibt ja nachgewiesene Fälle
deswegen weiß ich ja auch dass gerade
diese Kranken die ich erlitten habe
typischerweise auch sind wenn es auch
für einen singen Prozentzahl ist aber es
ist eben deutlich mehr als 0 also es
gibt diese Nebenwirkungen und es wird
doch immer aus der Politik vor allem
verkauft das geht gegen Null das kann
man völlig vernachlässigen sie das
Gefühl sie wurden genug aufgeklärt also
ich habe bei meiner Impfung überhaupt
nicht gewusst dass das keine
herkömmliche Impfung ist ich habe mich
jahrelang gegen Influenza impfen lassen
dachte dass wir auch so eine
impfstoffimpfung wie es da wäre und dass
man mit solch dramatischen Folgen
rechnen kann hat man mir nicht gedacht
war glaube ich damals auch nicht bekannt
das ist ja jetzt im Nachhinein
aufgetaucht war ja diese ganzen Stoffe
ja auch nur vorläufig zugelassen worden
sind ohne den ganzen Test Zyklus zu
durchlaufen das heißt man kriegt erst
nach der Verabreichung der Impfung mit
mir überhaupt die neben Folgen sind und
möglicherweise in meinem Fall hat also
das Gefühl da gibt es einen ganz starken
Zusammenhang zwischen seiner
Krankheitsgeschichte und der Corona
Impfung Peter da ist das Gefühl dass
Menschen die diese Annahme haben zu sehr
alleine gelassen werden
muss ein paar Sachen auseinander das ist
ein ganz dramatisches Schicksal wir
kennen alle keine Mediziner wie wir
sitzen wir wissen nicht ob wir
Zusammenhang tatsächlich dahin als
Richter nicht erzählen da ist Forschung
notwendig die ist da die ist meines
Erachten nicht ausreichend es ist auch
die Betreuung durch Ärzte oder die
Information auch der Ärzte ist nicht
genügend wenn man dann auf dem Land
wohnt und beim normal Landarzt ist dann
gute Nacht Marie weil die sind in der
Regel nicht richtig aufgeklärt also da
kommt ganz viel auf dem Hausarzt drauf
an und auf die Krankenkassen wir müssen
aber aufpassen dass er nicht schon so
tun als als sei immer gesagt worden dass
sie komplett nebenwirkungsfrei sind das
ist nicht nein das ist nie gesagt und
was die komplett nebenwirkungsfrei sind
nein also Herr Lauterbach hat das gesagt
da gab es eine Klage deswegen also ganz
klar getwittert das Arzneimittel sein
nebenwirkungsfrei das stimmt das war ein
riesen Skandal also der damals
zuständige Gesundheitsminister hieß
nicht lauter macht sondern sparen und
ich glaube nicht dass ihm Satz von ihm
damals zuständigen Gesundheitsminister
Spanien finden der sehr sagt dass diese
Mittel nebenwirkungsfrei sind sondern in
allen in allen in allen Publikationen
stand drinne das ist Nebenwirkung haben
kann es gibt eine Dokumentation
übernehmen Wirkung dass die Mittel dann
haben sie völlig Recht die waren
vorläufig zugelassen das ging damals
auch nie auch nicht anders verschlecht
und ergreifend der erprobungszeitraum
sonst noch ein paar Jahre gedauert hätte
sonst wäre das so wie es damals war so
dramatisch weitergegangen und ich kann
sagen ich war vor bevor sie Übungen gab
lag ich mit covit im Krankenhaus so ein
Stück vor der Intensivstation dass sie
nicht auf den auf der Intensivstation
lag hat nur damit zu tun dass ich vorher
bei einer guten Ärztin war meine
Hausärztin hat mich vorher nicht betreut
ich bin dann von Kollegen meiner Frau zu
einer infektiologin dann geschickt
worden und so eine immunologin die so
versiert war dass ich als ich ins
Krankenhaus kam schon alle Werte die man
innerhalb der nächsten drei Tage hätte
erheben müssen schon da waren und
dadurch hat man mich quasi vor der
Intensivstation noch gerettet aber das
war niemand hat gesagt dass sie
nebenwirkungsfrei sind es ist ein
dramatischer Fall und und ich will ihn
auch nicht absprechen das ist
von der Impfung kommen kann aber wir
müssen aufpassen dass sie nicht so tun
als sei das ein Massenphänomen als sein
die meisten Leute die geimpft worden
sind krank geworden es gibt dramatische
Folgen da ist Forschung wirklich
notwendig da ist auch eine bessere
Betreuung bin ich voll die völlig bei
ihm nur nötig da muss auch geguckt
werden ob man da unter Umständen dann
entschädigen muss aber es ist nicht das
Massenphänomen
frei ist
gleichzeitig sofort gleichzeitig die
Impfkampagne natürlich trotzdem weiter
wie stehen Sie dazu im siehe das Gefühl
man sollte man kann sich jetzt noch
einfach impfen lassen oder sind doch
Geschichten wie diese etwas die sie zum
Nachdenken anregen finde sie haben das
ja sehr sachlich gerade dargestellt und
niemand hat jetzt gesagt dass das
Massenphänomen ist oder sowas das kann
ja vielleicht noch kommen wissen wir
noch nicht alle ich kenne auch
persönlich Leute wo es sehr
wahrscheinlich ist dass das Impfen
Nebenwirkung ist und auch Sportler aber
wahrscheinlich
habe ich ja gesagt ich habe nicht gesagt
dass es so ist aber es wurde schon so
auch wenn man es nicht wortwörtlich
gesagt hat der Spanier tatsächlich nicht
gesagt aber es wurde schon so gerührt
dass sei alles harmlos machen sie mal
alles überhaupt kein Problem auch man es
kommt darauf an wie es beim Bürger
ankommt ich bin stinken Maler Bürger ich
gucke dass ich höre das und dann hat man
schon das Phänomen gehabt oder das war
so wahrgenommen hat passiert
nebenwirkungsfrei man muss das nicht
aussprechen Politik hat aber da an
Glaubwürdigkeit verloren das ist einfach
nur Unterstellung zu sagen dass die
Politik mit Absicht suggeriert das habe
ich doch gar nicht gesagt
gerade
suche Kinder impfen ganz ehrlich wie
viele kenne ich diese ihre Kinder
geimpft haben wo ich gesagt habe mein
Gott das kannst du nicht machen sie sind
mir doch sicherlich eine Meinung dass
sie oder so weit ich weiß ja na klar
gesagt was haben sie gesagt und da
schauen wir jetzt einmal rein
sich wirklich was noch passieren muss
bis wirklich der letzte versteht dass
diese Impfung einen selbst zuerst einmal
schützt aber eben vor allem auch für uns
alle als Gesellschaft
dann auch Sicherheit gibt insofern sehe
ich eine unbedingte moralische
Verpflichtung sich impfen zu lassen wenn
wir uns
ums Arme Impfung zu nutzen um uns selbst
und andere vor tote schwere Krankheit zu
schützen würden wir die Pandemie
wahrscheinlich nie beenden können
weltweit sind Hunderte von Millionen
Menschen mit den modernen Impfstoffen
geimpft es sind also eine erhebliche
Zeit verstrichen und deshalb können wir
heute wirklich sagen die Impfstoffe sind
sehr sicher und sehr wirksam und
trotzdem haben wir noch 15 Millionen
Erwachsene in Deutschland die das
impfangebot offenbar nicht wahrnehmen
wollen
so haben wir also reingehört jetzt
können wir hier mit diesen Informationen
am Tisch auch arbeiten und ich habe das
Gefühl dass jedem etwas auf den Lippen
legt jeder jetzt gerne der erste sein
möchte der hat Informationen also sie
haben jetzt drei drei Personen aus der
Politik gezeigt also der Herr Spahn zum
Beispiel hat immer behauptet das ist
jetzt hier nicht gezeigt worden es ist
eine ordentliche Zulassung der EU nein
es war eine bedingte Zulassung der EU
mit der Maßgabe ist eine gibt bestimmte
Verordnung 507.2 in der man im zehnten
erwähnungsgrundsatz darauf hingewiesen
hat dass das Gesundheitswesen so wie das
die gesamte Bevölkerung darüber
aufgeklärt werden muss dass man keine
Nebenwirkungen noch nicht kennen kann
weil eben die Studien und die klinische
und zwar also die zweite klinische
Studie durch die immer noch bis Dezember
2023 noch laufen wird erstens trotzdem
hat er gesagt es wäre eine ordentliche
Zulassung der EU zweitens Helge Braun
hat in Mannheimer immer Morgenmagazin
erwähnt
ich leider jetzt nicht hier gezeigt
worden es wäre eine sterile Immunität
die es auslöst und das wissen wir er ist
Mediziner und wir wissen ganz genau es
löst keinen fremdschutz aus es löst
keine sterile Immunität aus im Gegenteil
das heißt er war Mediziner und er sprach
davon das wissen wir ich kenne keine
einzige Studie in der man davon gewusst
hätte weil es nämlich immer gegenteilig
behauptet wurde Herr Lauterbach hat auf
Zwitter behauptet es wäre
nebenwirkungsfrei da gab es tatsächlich
eine Klage in diesem Falle wurde dann
eben vom Gericht gesagt es wäre
Meinungsfreiheit was ich nicht
nachvollziehen kann weil er hat es
nämlich als Gesundheitsminister gesagt
und das halte ich für unwahre
unverantwortlich es war nie
nebenwirkungsfrei es gibt gar kein
Arzneimittel das nebenwirkungsfrei ist
und was die Masse der möglichen im
Schäden betrifft sind wir noch ganz ganz
ganz am Anfang es gibt eine immer
Datenbank da sind wir bei ich glaube
zwei Millionen Verdachtsfällen
mittlerweile und Verdachtsfälle von
40.000 Toten
es nagelt mich nicht fest das sind auf
jeden Fall schon die die Größe einer
Stadt und die klinischen Studien sind
nicht beendet also die zweite dritte
klinische Studie läuft noch und erst
danach kann man überhaupt beurteilen ob
langfristig Nebenwirkungen und Schäden
erzeugt werden können das heißt wir sind
ganz am Anfang dieser ganzen Methoden
und dass man eben eine bedingte
Zulassung erteilt hat ohne die Menschen
darüber zu informieren halte ich für ich
muss wirklich hart widersprechen ich
habe Jens Spahn in der während der
Corona Zeit und er zu dumm die
Impfstoffe gegen und auch um die
Zulassung die Impfstoffe geht mehrfach
interviewt das ist auch nachließbar und
nachschaubar entspannt hat nie nicht
erwähnt das ist eine bedingte Zulassung
ist
betont er hat es niemals also vielleicht
aber ganz gut also das geht so nicht
wenn ich sage ich habe ihn gesprochen
und er hat mir gesagt dann können sie
nicht einfach sagen das hat nicht
stattgefunden so kann man nicht
diskutieren was sie mit ihm geredet
haben ich kann nur sagen was die Videos
zu finden ist im Internet
jeder gegenüber einem 16-jährigen
Mädchen übers Mikrofon vor ungefähr 100
Leuten wo er klar gesagt hat es ist eine
ordentliche Zulassung
es ist eine ordentliche Zulassung und
bei diesem wahlkampfgespräch ordentliche
Zulassungen
lassen Sie mich bitte mal ausreden
Dankeschön in diesem wahlkampfgespräch
das war 2021 kurz vorm Herbst hat er
rumgedruckst und drum gedruckt bis diese
16-jährige Mädchen ihm wirklich aus dem
Mund gequetscht hat dass er zugeben
musste es ist eine bedingte Zulassung
waren sie das Interview gehabt haben
doch gar nicht anders möglich gewesen
der Zeitraum hat nichts anderes
zugelassen aus ihrer Logik heraus aber
wenn sie sich damit los und die
Gespräche durchsehen also alles was er
in der Öffentlichkeit gesagt hat bis
2021 im September habe ich nicht einmal
gelesen dass er von einer bedingten
Zulassung gesprochen ich habe einen
anderen problematischen Punkt eben bei
den Zitaten und da bin ich ja auch
wieder auf ihre Linie das ist der
moralischen Druck der aufgebaut worden
ist
so da zu sagen es besteht eine
moralische Verantwortung dafür sind
Politiker sticht unter greifen nicht
zuständig die sind für Recht und Gesetz
zuständig sind dafür zuständig dass
bestimmte Sachen den Regeln entsprechend
durchgeführt werden das hinterher
vielleicht wenn es dann schwere im
Stehen gibt dass das erforscht wird das
dann auch Hilfe bereitgestellt werden
dafür sind Politiker zuständig aber
nicht dafür aber nicht dafür uns
moralischen Kompass zu geben da bin ich
dahin bei einem anderen Musik muss ich
wirklich sagen Vorsicht ähm es geht
aufgrund des Zeitraumes wäre eine andere
Zulassung überhaupt nicht möglich
gewesen als eine beliebte weil nämlich
die studienzeiträume viel viel länger
sind dann hätten wir heute vielleicht
jetzt mal die erste Impfung also das mag
ja alles so sein aber dann muss man die
Menschen darüber informieren also
immer zum zum Bild lesen weil in der
Bild was genau erklärt was ist eine
bedingte Zulassung in der Bild-Zeitung
war im Februar 2021 gestanden wenn du
geimpft bist bist
weiter kommen ich glaube es gab eine
Einigung bei dem Punkt
das ist eine zumindest moralische
Verpflichtung gab die suggeriert wurde
mehr möchte ich da gar nichts dafür ich
möchte von Herrn Tank noch einmal
abholen wie es bei Ihnen jetzt
weitergeht sie haben hier gerade ihren
Weg geschildert sie sind jetzt wieder
frisch zurück im Job nach all der
Leidensgeschichte man konnte kaum mit
zehn Herzinfarkt Schlaganfall Stent
gesetzt also da haben sie wirklich was
hinter sich jetzt sind sie frisch im Job
was würde Ihnen helfen was sind ihre
Erwartungen was fordern sie denn jetzt
ich möchte natürlich irgendwann nicht
mehr sagen müssen es spricht
überwiegendes dafür nicht würde er immer
gerne sagen müssen es steht fest das ist
ein Leben Schaden ist oder steht fest
dass es keinen im Schaden ist das müsste
man natürlich irgendwann rausfinden und
äh wenn man eben zum Ergebnis kommen
sollte dass nachweisbar ist das ist ein
im Schaden ist dass ähm mir natürlich
dann auch geholfen mit dauerhaft gesund
zu werden also jetzt sind wir auf dem
stand dass ich Ende des Jahres noch mal
einen Termin bekomme um das dauerhaft zu
beheben weil bis jetzt bekomme ich ähm
gute Mittel um
die tortenbildung zu verhindern um
erstmal auf der sicheren Seite zu sein
sonst würde ich wahrscheinlich jede
Woche ein Herz und Farbraum aus welchem
Grund auch immer und das geht es
natürlich dann zu vermeiden sonst muss
ich mich erstmal zurechtfinden also ich
darf noch nicht wieder 100% arbeiten das
muss ich meinen ersten versprechen dass
ich mich erstmal noch zurückhalte und
dann jetzt wieder ins Leben zurückführen
ich bin ja schon froh dass ich jetzt
nicht mehr in einer Klinik bin sondern
wieder am Berufsleben teilnehmen kann
und auch wieder an meinem allgemeinen
Leben teilnehmen kann vielleicht früher
oder Gewohnheiten auch wieder aufgreifen
kann die jetzt die letzten Monate
natürlich völlig verschwunden sind dabei
wünschen wir Ihnen natürlich ganz viel
Kraft dass sie einfach auch in das alte
Leben wieder richtig zurück finden noch
letzte Frage an Sie wie fühlen sie sich
es wird jetzt ein bisschen auch
zurückgerudert es gibt hier und damals
ein Einsehen eine Entschuldigung wie
wirkt das danach das finde ich natürlich
gut dass inzwischen das nicht tut
geschrieben wird sondern dass man auch
in sogenannten Medien der ist aus dem
mindestens Bereich auch die Zeitung die
meinen Bereich hat ist offen auch über
im Opfer und im Schäden gesprochen wird
oder den Verdacht jedenfalls ich finde
es schon gut dass das nicht unter den
Teppich gekehrt wird sondern man das
ganze auch anspricht und egal ob man nun
gesagt hat das sei impf Folgen frei oder
auch nicht so eine solche dramatischen
Folgen sind natürlich so nicht klar
gemacht worden und das wäre natürlich
gut wenn man also auch klarstellen dass
es gute Gründe gibt sich nicht irgendwie
zu lassen wenn man das ganze abwägt wie
ist das Risiko ist
beschrieben auch man kann sehr sehr
erhebliche Folgen davon haben und wo wir
19 zu erkranken man kann aber auch wie
man ja inzwischen weiß sehr erhebliche
Folgen haben wenn man sich impfen lässt
das muss also jeder abwägen wenn man
dann moralischen Druck erzeugt der dann
bei jedem einzelnen dazu führt zu sagen
ich blende mal meine Person völlig aus
ich Opfer mich für die Allgemeinheit auf
ist das vielleicht auf Dauer nicht der
richtige Weg würden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
für Sie